what's up you guys it's the movie
retrospective going back to the 70s and
talking about some Hammer horror yeah
although
well this one is um even among like
horror Hammer aficionados is kind of
seen as one of the Lesser uh entries
into the series this is I mean because
this came along this is Dracula A.D
1972.
by the time this movie came out I mean
Hammer was kind of they're back now but
you know they were kind of in a downward
spiral a little bit I think actually
they closed the studio up like just a
couple years after this came out so I'm
not blaming this movie on that entirely
I'm just saying that it was just kind of
like it's not bad it's not a bad movie
it's not it's just not in classic uh a
hammer style you know with Victorian
outfits and medieval type outfits you
know and castles and [ __ ] it's not like
that it's it was contemporary for the
time it's happening in 1972. and it
tries to go real contemporary they got
music in there you know yeah bell
bottoms sounds like black exploitation
yeah it would be a little bit yeah it's
a little bit jarring checks and drugs
and everything uh but you know and
Dracula's in the mix
um and it's kind of like a police
Prestige rule too and then you got Peter
Cushing in there is like [ __ ] van
Hills ex descended it's not a bad movie
no it's pretty good
um the only thing I can knock it for is
there's not enough Dracula in it I mean
if you got if you got you know if you
got Dracula you better give him a lot of
lines he better be a damn character
um in this one he's more kind of like a
monster that shows up at the end
yeah that's the only thing I didn't like
about he's not yeah he's not in it much
I think a lot of people I mean there's a
lot of things that people don't like
about this particular movie but I think
one of the things that they don't like
is like you've got Christopher Lee and
Peter Cushing yeah and they're
underutilized I feel like like Peter
Cushing has like a bigger part than
Christopher Lee does yeah but
Christopher Lee is not is hardly in it
yeah and it's like even when he is there
it's like he's not really given a great
deal to do no like you would kind of
think that if they were calling it
Dracula 80 1972 you would get some like
interaction between Dracula and the
modern era yeah but you don't really
have that they don't really do that and
you know Blacula and Screen black and
scream did a good job of of a vampires
in the 1970s and you know [ __ ] Mama
Waldy you know who is blackular [ __ ]
Mama Waldy had a lot of [ __ ] to do and a
lot of lines so you got to know that
character rule I would like to see
because
right Christopher Lee is he's a good
Dracula yeah he's taking a Dracula I
always like him he's a good drag it's
not Baila but it is just a different
interpreter he's the English Dracula
okay
um he's physically imposing he sounds
like it sounds and looks like he's
[ __ ] in charge all right that you
don't want to mess with this dude
um so let's have him stunting let's have
him bragging about his Heritage and how
he's commanded Nations you know what I
mean who are you to even threaten me Van
Helsing I have commanded Nations for
centuries you know yeah okay let's hear
more about that man he he doesn't give
not enough lines
yeah he's really not and the thing about
it I mean poor Christopher Lee at this
point uh this was the seventh movie I
think that he played Dracula in and he
would only do one more because he was
like kind of sick of it at this point
um the one after this one which is also
pretty reviled by audiences uh which is
called the satanic Rites of Dracula that
was the last time that he would play
Dracula because he didn't really like
the idea of bringing Dracula up to the
modern era like he more liked him in his
own time period like when it was
eduardian or Victorian or whatever and
he's like and he just thought it was a
dumb idea like bringing it up to the
modern era but the thing about it though
like I said Hammer at this point were
you know they weren't doing so well and
they were thinking well maybe
everybody's getting sick of these kind
of like just Gothic melodramas like you
know the old school monsters so they saw
the success of you know stuff like count
yorga which was I think that was uh
American International pictures AIP and
how that that was it wasn't about
Dracula but it was a vampire in the
modern era and they're like okay well
maybe we need like the youths like to
come see the stuff and so they're trying
to like revamp it so they just thought
oh we'll bring Dracula up to the modern
era but Christopher Lee was not a fan of
that idea so I mean he agreed to do it
but
I don't think he liked it all that much
I mean he didn't phone it in or anything
but he's not really in it all that much
yeah he probably told him to look yeah
I'll be in the movie but I don't want to
be in it very much maybe I mean he was
in the next one too but that was like
the last one you know what's crazy about
this to me is that you know because
everybody always makes a big deal like
it's always a good time like when you
have Peter Cushing and crisperly in the
same movie and the thing about it though
that I didn't even realize because I
guess I had thought because they were in
a lot of movies together but I thought
they were in more Dracula movies
together they said this was actually the
first time that they'd been like Dracula
Van Helsing since 1958 like the first
Dracula movie which is just called
Dracula in the UK but it's called Horror
of Dracula in the in the U.S so I was
like I that blew my mind like
Christopher Lee played Dracula like you
know in movies subsequently but I guess
he wasn't in them like when Peter
Cushing played uh Van Helsing I just
kind of thought so this was kind of like
a big deal because it was the first time
that it happened since 19 1958 but then
you know it just it didn't really do all
that well well it's just not fleshed out
enough from The Vampire angle it's more
like more like a police procedural if
you like police movies you'd like this
one because they spend most of their
time hunting down what they think is a
cult of satanic cult it is a satanical
kinda but there are vampires vampire uh
thralls basically is doing it and uh
they're not bad the actors that play the
actor that played um Dracula's main
thrall who was being promised to get to
get turned Johnny Alucard
he eventually does get turned is he's a
good actor and uh me and Jim were
talking we're commenting that he's a
real good looking guy everybody is good
looking in these Hammer flicks pretty
much you know he's a real good looking
guy and he would have made a really good
Lestat I was thinking that yeah he made
it real good the stat a lot of reviewers
pointed out too that they probably got
him because he gives off a real
um Malcolm McDowell from A Clockwork
Orange energy yeah like he does kind of
look like that as well and I think
that's kind of what they wanted you know
what I mean like they wanted that kind
of because I think Malcolm McDowell had
also opposing though I think McDowell
was kind of wiry and creepy but it's
still kind of magnetic in a certain way
this guy's kind of a little more buffed
out
yeah more leading man kinda really he'd
made a great list at he'd have made a
great let's start that's kind of yeah
yeah it looks like in the 80s that's
kind of like the look that I was
picturing like this guy but yeah I think
the thing about it is that I think they
they concentrate too much on the hippies
and the thing about it too is that this
came out in 1972 I think originally they
wanted it to come out in 1969. uh so it
wouldn't have been quite as dated but
the thing about it is that by the time
1972 had come along in London all of the
stuff that they're doing in this movie
like all the hippie stuff like the music
and the clothes they're wearing and
stuff was like several years out of date
you know what I mean so um I mean you
could tell that like older dudes like
wrote this and were like talking just
like what are the kids into today and
it's like you know they were like five
years
one of the hippies those wearing a
fantastic looking like goth witch kind
of outfit and made out of damn black
I guess beads and strings and [ __ ] looks
really good if you look it's Caroline
Monroe the Exquisite Carolina this was
kind of her first big movie I feel like
yeah and she's the first victim
basically offered up to Dracula and
Dracula just basically just eats her and
kills her uh doesn't even doesn't even
turn her into a vampire which is like
women hold on Dracula is supposed to be
about the ladies and he gets the hottest
one right off the bat just kills her
well he didn't want her he wanted well
the other one Jessica because Jessica
was Van Helsing like the current Dave
Van helsing's granddaughter that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying they he gets
his hands on the hottest one out of the
group and just kills her doesn't even
make her a vampire yeah uh you know like
what a waste what a waste
all right
uh you know had they been thinking about
it you know if this was Bayla lugosi's
Dracula he would have been impressed
because and added her to the harem
you know like we're gonna keep this one
but now he he killed that one
well see I think they kind of explained
because we're sitting here going because
I was like okay now I know that in the
original novel and I think like most of
the movies that were you know mostly
based on the original novel like you
know as soon as Dracula drank your blood
like a few times and then you died they
all came back as vampires right you
didn't necessarily need like the whole
blood exchange situation yeah so I was
wondering how that was gonna go with
this because he kills Caroline Monroe's
character first who I think her
character name is Laura actually she was
partially eaten too well see I think
that he didn't do that okay I think that
Johnny Alucard did that to make it look
like a serial killer did it or some
other like to kind of cover up the whole
fact that it was even though he took the
last name Alucard which obviously is
draculous build backwards yeah so well
yeah from several movies right well I
think this might have been the origin of
that though because I think like
somebody like took off with that idea
but I'm not sure it could have could
have been done before that but it's
still dumb so um so yeah but they
actually kind of because she doesn't
come back like they just find her body
like in the rubble like but by the
decommissioned Church where they were
doing the satanic right or whatever and
I was like oh so she's not gonna come
back as a vampire then I was like so I
guess we're all not coming back as
vampires but then I think they later on
said that oh well when he first came
when he when Dracula first got
resurrected he wasn't strong enough to
make other vampires yeah so he had to
like eat a few people because remember
he ate the other girl too like the one
that was named Gainer I think her name
was like he ate that girl too and I
don't think she came back as a vampire
but then Subs oh and he and he killed
somebody off screen that like we didn't
we didn't know who they were so I think
he killed three ladies first and then he
started like making vampires like he had
just like built up his strength I guess
yeah had this been had this been Bayless
[ __ ] Dracula or had it been Lestat he
wouldn't he wouldn't have been killing
hotties
uh he would he would have gone down uh
uh to the uh to the rough parts of
[ __ ] town and killed burglars or
killed [ __ ] muggers and drug dealers
and eating and drank them all right
that's what to gain his strength because
Lestat did that all the time yeah and he
killed a bunch of people the stat did
but he tend to Value people he liked
evil doers
he liked to kill he he he said they
tasted better
but I think I think what it was I think
in lestat's case he could just live with
it better
yeah that's probably what it was I think
he was lying to The Weave about their
tasted better he just didn't he didn't
he appreciated Beauty
because that was really the only thing
they could do
they couldn't do much else other than
appreciate Beauty they couldn't have sex
yeah so you know but uh it's not a bad
movie it's just it just fell short of of
a good vampire story because really man
let's be honest you're watching a
vampire movie because the vampire is the
most interesting character in the damn
movie so there's got to be a lot of them
and he has to be telling his story
in the Blacula the two Blacula movies
you got to hear Mama waldy's story
he even was interested in science and
technology and he was from the past
which makes a lot of sense that got
included in in the Lestat you know
interview of the vampire type books too
is that
you know when Lestat ended up in the
modern world because he'd been sleeping
for a long time he was amazed by
television and radio and uh
um cars he owned a Harley and he rode
motorcycles and stuff you know he did it
all at night but he had toys
and you would think that
you know a guy like Dracula would have
been really impressed with things like
television and music and uh modern
culture and he probably would have liked
the club life and and going out at night
and chasing women
um because it's boring just to hang out
and damn castles and kill people you
know and drink blood there's got to be
more to life the rest of the time you
know and really Dracula's a nobleman you
know yeah he was a warlord and commanded
Nations but he's a nobleman they they
did that [ __ ] so they could enjoy the
finer aspects of Life they appreciated
the art and music and people and clothes
and toys and so he would have had a lot
of [ __ ] and interest in a lot of stuff
they should have gotten into that you
know wherever she lived right yeah what
was he doing yeah
that's yeah I think that's kind of what
bothered me because like I said you know
and and you know Christopher Lee is
fantastic as always Peter Cushing is
fantastic as always neither of them
phone it in but I do kind of feel like
there was a good idea in here that they
could have explored but I think they
focused too much on the hippies and like
I said the whole hippie thing
um you know if you don't know like what
happens in the movie It's essentially
the same plot as Taste the Blood of
Dracula even though Taste the Blood of
Dracula was set like back in the
Victorian or Edwardian age like the
other ones but it's like that but in the
modern day where it's like a satanic
cult or a satanic dude who they kind of
imply that he was Dracula's buddy from
like back then you know what I mean and
so he had gathered up some of like
Dracula's ashes or whatever when Van
Helsing killed him a hundred years ago
and is like bringing him back into the
modern era like so he can be made into a
vampire so it's like a satanic cult
angle but I kind of feel like they just
spend too much time with the hippies and
the hippies are not really all that
interested and like I said it's just
kind of like you know and the fact too
that it's really kind of like out of
date like there's a there's a sequence
at the beginning where they like crash a
party like that has like these kind of
it's like upper class twits and everyone
is like all these old people with you
know pearls and diamonds on and they're
all like horrified at these what these
hippies are doing even though they're
not really doing anything else all that
Scandal is there's taken out underneath
the tables yeah and I'm just like and
playing rock music yeah it's like it's
so yeah they just all the old people
look aghast and I'm like they're not
even doing anything it's not like
they're [ __ ] yeah I don't know
they're not doing anything yeah I mean
but we're right I mean the only thing
interesting about a vampire movies are
really is the vampires and they should
have figured that out a long time ago
and I think some of the B movies in the
50s figured that out they tried to put
as much as the vampire in there as
possible
um the rest of the people use you don't
you see a vampire movie to see the
vampires
and and rice got it right is where you
make the story about from the vampire's
point of view and the relationships
between the vampires and what they're
doing
and that's really that's the best way to
tell that story and really this would
have been a good movie had it just been
told
more from that thrall's point of view
now you know the you know the uh yeah
yeah from his point of view and him
dealing with Dracula and what Dracula's
telling him do and then he every time he
sees Dracula and goes back to trackless
pad he's Dracula's messing with more and
more stuff like now he's studying
nuclear reactors and you know he's into
he's trying to build an airplane or he's
buying an airplane because he wants to
fly there's just a bunch of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] they could have done like what
would Dracula be interested in modern
stuff if he was in the center yeah I'm
like if you're gonna bring it up to the
modern era at least put Dracula in that
context right because in the movie
Dracula literally like they resurrect
him in like a decommissioned church
that's kind of being torn down or
whatever I don't think he ever leaves
that like other than to pop around and
like kill people every now and then but
he you don't ever see him like out in
the Streets of London or you don't ever
see him doing like modern [ __ ] it's
because they're trying to evoke that
damn atmosphere of old of an old vampire
movie where it's Dracula in Castle
Dracula
right that doesn't that doesn't
necessarily make a vampire movie though
you know vampire could be if as long as
you're telling the story the right way
he can be in any setting yeah I mean it
worked before like you know it worked in
the when you had them that set like you
know in the Victorian era and era
because that's just kind of like what
you did back then yeah like I said if if
you're gonna update the vampire story to
1972 then put him in 1972. you don't
just have him stay in the church though
yeah Mama Waldy Mama Waldy was going to
you know he was uh down in the hood
going to the clubs and [ __ ] listening to
Funk and disco music right and chasing
Pam Grier what are you chasing Pam Grier
he was yeah yeah and uh you know and
that worked and that worked and they're
gonna say Jack you got some fine threads
he's like well thank you very much
and then he'd hold these conversations
with Mortals and stuff and and it was
you know and and drinking what was his
name Marshall William Marshall William
Marshall William Marshall yeah he he he
carried that role yeah he killed it yeah
he's great in Star Trek too man the M5
computer remember this yeah great voice
that guy has the M5 but see that's the
thing like Christopher Lee could could
have totally pulled that off yeah like I
know that he's not a big fan of like
bringing Dracula up to the modern day or
he wasn't back then but the thing about
the reason everybody likes Christopher
Lee and Peter Cushing is because even if
the you know maybe the idea of the movie
was silly or unbelievable or something
like that they had conviction you know
what I mean and like them acting the way
they acted like made you believe it too
like Peter Cushing for real like in this
because I think I even said it when we
were watching it I was just like man
I'll believe anything Peter Cushing says
just because he takes everything very
very seriously and honestly I did I
liked all this stuff too like I liked
the police procedural kind of thing with
you know Peter Cushing like interacting
with um kiddo because they are they go
to Peter Cushing's character because
he's a descendant of the original Van
Helsing and he is also an expert on the
occult and they think that they were
some kind of like satanic angle to these
murders so they go to him for like you
know to consult with him or whatever and
he gets to a point where he's pretty
sure that you know it's an actual
vampire that's and you know then he has
to like convince the cops of that so I
didn't even mind any of that I didn't
actually mind the character of Jessica
who was his granddaughter and was one of
the friends like of the in the hippie
group or whatever she's actually played
by Stephanie Beacham who was um she was
on Dynasty I think among many other
things and yeah she's got some uh some
big old bosoms in this as well they show
them a lot
yeah they got like a bunch of shots
where she's like kind of like leaning
over backwards like that with big old
titties
I knew the formula yeah okay that was
that that was their tradition this is
it's pretty boobalicious this one the
[ __ ] hey man hammers guys are liver
yeah but I really think they should have
had a bunch of scenes with Christopher
Lee
in his new mansion with a wall full of
televisions each one of them on a
different Channel he can watch them all
at one time using his vampire powers
he's got a instead of an organ he's got
a brand new [ __ ] synthesizer that he
can [ __ ] do awesome you know cool
music with it a whole wardrobe of cool
70s clothes that are you know kind of
like vampiric goth you know Black Velvet
looking stuff yeah because they had some
of the thralls were wearing that kind of
stuff yeah because Johnny Alucard looks
kind of like that like he looked like he
had some crushed velvet kind of like
situation going yeah yeah which was you
know and uh Dracula would have been in
in the height of fashion you know he'd
be like okay what's what's hit this year
and he would that's what he would have
gone for it wouldn't have been the 1800s
early 1900s uh look that uh Bella had
you know that was maybe height of
fashion back then but no
Dracula would have been up to date so he
could have gone anywhere he would look
like a celebrity get a celebrity pimp
really
yeah I definitely think I think should
have gone well see the thing about it is
that I think at this point like I said
because Hammer was kind of like on a
downward Trend at this point and would
close like a few years subsequently I
think they were just kind of chasing the
tail of the trend they're like you know
count yorga came out actually Blacula
came out the same year as this but um
they were kind of like they saw the
writing on the wall they're like well
nobody wants to see Gothic horror
anymore nobody wants to see Dracula back
in musty old castles anymore we need to
like update it like count yorga did and
I think that it was just like a little
too late and I don't think they cared
that much about
getting the story like you know really
kind of reconciling uh the character
with the modern day it seems like they
didn't really put a great deal of
thought into it come to think of it
modernized 1970s vampire pimp who you're
talking about as you're talking about
Elvis with this black belt his black
velvet [ __ ]
they look like Hammer horror like you
evidently liked hamburger horror movies
he liked vampires and stuff he knew a
male and army known as Vampira so you
know Elvis kind of went goth in the 70s
from you know Black Velvet and the high
collars and the red shirts red on black
you know and then sometimes just white
and that's how Dracula probably would
address yeah you would think he would go
oh I'm gonna go for what you know
Cutting Edge fashion that kind of harks
back to an earlier age you know what I
mean [ __ ] and that's probably what we
would have gone probably a little top
hat or something you know [ __ ] like
like you know that's still popular in
the Golf Scene today [ __ ] Pride
platforms yeah yeah yeah
I mean that's man's platform like I said
it's just kind of a shame because I just
kind of feel like it was a little bit I
don't want to go so far to say it was
maybe a cash grab but I don't think they
put a great deal of thought into
really kind of exploring all the Avenues
that you could have explored I mean
basically it just seemed like there was
like Dracula and Peter you know Dracula
and Van Helsing their kind of stuff
which honestly didn't even have to be
said in the modern era because it was
just kind of the same kind of fights
that they had like back in the old days
but then like with some hippie stuff
tacked on yeah and the hippie stuff like
I said wasn't really all that
interesting like Caroline Monroe was
good
um you know I liked kind of like the
Johnny Alucard thing although man Johnny
Alucard he died like a Chomp didn't he
yeah he got killed by a shower yeah it
was uh he yeah that was another
underutilized character and not
developed well enough for the movie
um he should have been a little more
sympathetic I think and
um then more interesting once he turned
into a vampire they didn't really make
him that interesting he didn't say what
it was like being a vampire yeah and he
died like he's not like not too long
after he got made into a vampire because
honestly he just like he basically
whined his way into being why kryanna
cry his way into it into it and once he
got it you don't hear anything about it
he doesn't come oh man now I can do this
and oh no man this is what it feels like
look at look at what I can do there's
none of that which that's what makes a
vampire [ __ ] movie yeah is to see
somebody transforming what can they do
now you know because you're kind of when
you watch these things you're kind of
living vicariously through the vampire
characters like what would I do what
does that feel like wish I could do that
yeah you know I wish I could hover two
feet off the ground when you pissed me
off
I wish I could just look at you and you
just freeze you and then just like you
know mentally dominate you by staring at
you you know what I mean vampires can do
that yeah well let's see that let's see
what let's hear about what that's like
because you had that character you have
him so let's use him who obviously
really really wanted to be a vampire so
badly that he went the whole Satanic
ritual and like woke Dracula up from 100
years ago yeah yeah and then once he's
got this power you should be able to go
on a little journey with him and him and
through growth you've seen him grow as a
vampire maybe you start rooting for him
but then he's killed see and that's a
lot more of an effective
they maybe could have done that like
they could have like maybe I killed him
later in the movie yeah right before
Dracula or had him turned on Dracula for
some reason something like that try to
turn on Dracula to gain Dracula's power
but that doesn't work and he's killed
yeah I like that he's like he's like
[ __ ] you Dracula I'm gonna take your
place you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah see they should have had me writing
these things man I'm not even a writer
okay I can well like I said they seemed
like they didn't really but he didn't
care care all that much about it I think
they were just kind of like I don't
think too even in the 1970s even though
the hammer movies were successful I
don't think that they really
they really didn't like um understand
the lasting impact that those movies
would have that people would still be
talking about them 50 years later you
know and and everything I think they for
them it was just kind of like yeah we
just kind of like need to make something
that like makes us some money and it's
like this is the way the trend is going
so let's make one like that yeah I don't
really think they thought that much
about it and they had Caroline Monroe on
there who was the hottest chick in this
movie and they kill her early yeah she
got a case she was the first one that
got killed yeah and that was just like
what the [ __ ] are they doing
you know what I mean
that would have been great motive all
right what would happen if the Carolyn
Monroe character got turned as a vampire
and she was a vampire along with the
Alucard guy through the whole thing
right and in the end
Alucard gets killed because he tries to
prevent Dracula from getting making that
one his bride so they're fighting over
over her that would have been the
[ __ ] story I would have told and he
loses that fight all right and then
Dracula gets her you know or he tries to
get her away from Dracula and a fight
breaks out that kind of thing you know
uh but then they're all kind of killed
basically that's how that story was or
no they're not killed what if what if
Dracula gets away at the end why does
Dracula have to die at the end you're
going to resurrect him when you make it
I mean seriously well I mean they yeah
they made another movie just let him
live like a couple years later they
killed satanic writes they talk about
how bad Dracula is and at the end of
every one of those movies track that
dies like a [ __ ]
why don't you just let him get away so
you can make another movie I kind of
feel like he didn't die as much of like
like a [ __ ] as he has in a couple of
the other Hammer movies yeah they still
die easy though but yeah they do kind of
get killed sort of I I think if I
remember correctly it's been a while
since I've seen it but I think Taste the
Blood of Dracula had him dying like yeah
really like a [ __ ] so at least in this
one you think he dies like a [ __ ] but
then like just getting stabbed by Van
Helsing because but then he comes back
out and he's like the surprise
[ __ ] so it was like that kind of
thing
um and I will say he does die like a
[ __ ] though he falls into a hole that
has spikes in it and a little a little
90 pound van helsig [ __ ] jumps on him
to finish him off well he pushes no he
doesn't he pushes us he pushes him down
on the spikes with a shovel oh with a
shovel that's right I've never cut his
head off with the shovel no he was
pushing him down onto the onto the
spikes like farther into Spike so he
couldn't get out right but yeah that's
that's why Peter Cushing weighs about 90
pounds okay it's soaking wet that dude's
all just Skin and Bones right
[ __ ]
wish I had those cheekbones but you
gotta weigh 90 pounds to have those
cheekbones and then have all your
[ __ ] back teeth pulled out probably
the
he probably had probably didn't have any
molars you know I wonder man there's no
one Peter cushion it was so [ __ ] cool
he was like one of the coolest looking
dudes ever yeah and like I said cooler
the older he got the yeah the cooler he
looks he just looks cooler well and the
thing about Peter Cushing that's so
awesome and why he's always so good and
he loved playing Van Helsing too this
was one of his favorite roles is that
like I said he takes everything super
super seriously and you just he has such
gravitas that you just like buy whatever
it's like it could be totally silly and
serious and everything and honestly one
of the things that I liked about this
movie was
um you know Peter Cushing his first he's
named Lorimer isn't he I don't know why
they didn't call like the original Van
Helsing like back in 1872 which I'll get
into that in a minute because the
continuities [ __ ] up with that but the
original Van Helsing for back then they
said his name was Lawrence I was like
what happened to Abraham I thought his
first name was Abraham but I was like I
don't know but the one in the modern day
is named they're making this year yeah
that's what I mean
I can check that it's like what was his
name Larry whatever I don't care so it's
just just write it down what the [ __ ]
his name is
[ __ ] like that yeah
I mean you know bugs Van Helsing
whatever so it's just kind of like
um I actually really liked the kind of
relationship like him and his
granddaughter because he gets involved
too because he realizes that it's his
granddaughter's friend group that are
being picked off one by one and that
she's involved somehow and obviously
Dracula wants her because I think he
wants to turn her into a vampire
specifically because like just as a kind
of like [ __ ] you to Van Helsing you know
what I mean because he's like oh you
guys hate vampires so much so I'm gonna
turn your but your beloved relative into
one which like I said I think they did
that and Taste the Blood of Dracula too
that's another one thinking about it
which like I said was kind of the same
story with these titles so I could just
hear it's there they would have inspired
me to write some badass stories and then
they kind of come up with these kind of
half-baked kind of stories yeah like the
satanic rights of Dracula I'm imagining
that I'm already kind of a story for
that yeah in my mind even though that
was much better with this one yeah and
it has some of the same characters like
it still has a satanic occult like thing
obviously yeah and you know I met and
I'm guaranteeing you what I can come up
with me better than what they come up
with yeah I don't think a lot of people
like satanic rights exactly you Taste
the Blood of Dracula I think I can come
up with some good [ __ ] that's you going
around making other people into vampires
I mean that yeah the titles are good
yeah yeah now the one that was before
this was scars of Dracula and that was
1970. and that was came out of 1970. but
the thing about it though is that at the
very beginning of this movie Dracula 80
1972 there's like a fight that happens
in 1872 between Dracula and Van Helsing
where like Van Helsing kills Dracula
with the still played by Peter cushion
yeah yeah that's what I mean because
everybody everybody looks exactly like
their great grandparents yeah yeah
just like all 15 of them it's the same
actor playing me like 100 years from now
yeah but yeah so um so he kills Dracula
with like a um like a carriage wheel
like a broken carriage wheel and then
but see the thing about it is that
that's supposed to happen and that
happened in 1872 it very clearly says
1872 but all the other Dracula movies
that were set back in the Victorian
Edwardian era they very specifically
said that that happened in 1885. so that
so I'm like so now you're saying the dry
that Van Helsing killed Dracula like 15
years like or 14 or 16 years before they
even met each other yeah like it's right
so they did like I said they didn't even
care about the continuity they just
wanted it to be 1872 because they wanted
it to be a hundred years yeah like 1972.
so that's why so it didn't make any
sense like with the older ones but like
I said they didn't really care they're
like oh yeah the artist doesn't give a
[ __ ] whatever yeah
that's probably not and like I said they
probably didn't have any concept that
like 50 years later like people were
still going to be like watching them and
talking about they were like it'll go by
so fast on the screen they'll forget it
it won't matter they didn't realize they
didn't there was before VHS because
there was even a scene in this movie
there's even a scene in this movie where
Peter Cushing writes down the name
Alucard because that's Johnny's last
name and then like very meticulously
like passed away lines on his team oh my
God it's Dracula backwards I'm like
that's right drag to the backwards
everybody figured that out already like
the first time you said it so it's a way
it's like I said I bought it because it
was Peter Cushing and he just like took
it very seriously and I was just like oh
okay that's some good [ __ ] but like he's
supposed to be like a really smart dude
and it's like you don't you wouldn't
have to write it down for heaven's sakes
you know what I mean and then he says it
to the cop and the cops like oh yeah
you're right I'm like wow you guys are
really not that bright are you I like
figure this out haven't you seen this
movie but yeah I mean this was kind of
like
I think it's kind of like an important
movie it's not so much it wasn't the
first one like I said that put the
vampire in the modern era because count
yorga came out before that that wasn't
Dracula but this was among the first
movies I think that put Dracula in the
modern day so in a way it's kind of I
mean at least it was the first big like
popular movie that did that it's not a
bad movie it's it's not it's not in the
context of his time it was probably per
it was okay it's pretty good
um it got [ __ ] reviews though even at
the time yeah yeah what'd they say
um a lot of people just said you know
that's like the same kind of [ __ ] we're
saying it's like you know the hippies
aren't that interesting it's like why
why like you have Peter Cushing and
Christopher why aren't you using them
okay like put them in the movie more
right um you know have Dracula interact
with the modern era if you're gonna yeah
yeah so it's like even back then like it
was similar aside from our complaints
it's not it's a Well executed it's
watchable it's still watchable the uh
it's got a good looking cast
um from the from this era the British
and European uh actors they deliver uh
on a lot of levels one they can act two
they're good looking oh they uh
they have good fashion even though it
might be dated in this the outfits are
still kind of cool yeah uh it's just
like I said they look more like
something from the 60s like from the
monkeys yeah that's what I yeah that's a
lot of people complained about that too
because they just said this was you know
if this had come out in 1964. it
probably would have been better than uh
then this would have been like very of
the moment but since it's 1972 not so
much the only one that uh uh kind of
looked like something that was the 70s
and futurists it was Carolyn Monroe's
dance outfit with the black the black
goth outfit yeah kind of because you
could actually wear that yeah yeah and
you'd get away with it especially if you
had a good set of boots with it with the
buckles and [ __ ] it would it would go
that would go well yeah you could
totally wear that nobody want to look at
you it's more like a witch outfit yeah
um and that's and and which outfits are
Timeless Yeah dance witch
Carolyn Monroe dance witch yeah
and uh boy and she's cute in this and
she just got cuter as it went uh [ __ ]
grew up my babysitter taking me in
California to the to the matinee in the
uh and to see uh Sinbad she was in the
Sinbad movies and uh Journey to the
Center of the Earth she was in that one
her at Earth's core Earth's core yeah
she was in that too right yeah yeah
so I think this is a little bit later
than this yeah so I'm old enough to have
seen those in the theater when I was a
little kid yeah Princess Leia would take
me my little baby said Kimmy she looked
just like Princess Leia I got
photographs to prove it too man I showed
it on prior show she looked like a
little um
um
look like a 14 year old Carrie Fisher
she's probably about 15. but um
yeah just Carolyn Monroe I didn't know
what her name was but I kept seeing her
over and over again in those British
movies yeah and [ __ ] everybody loved
her and she was on all those damn
fan magazines like fangoria and stuff
they'd have her in there
remember yeah she was kind of like a
little bit like a scream Queen for a
while a little bit I mean maybe more of
the like minor ones but like yeah but
she was in a bunch of like horror and
sci-fi and I think that this movie like
her being in this movie was kind of like
a stepping stone up to that because this
was one of the this was one of the first
big movies that she did like you know in
the horror genres I remember one of
those one of those uh Sinbad movies that
I I saw I think she was in eye of the
tiger I think yeah we'd we'd just
watched them not too long ago and she
was in one of them right was she in the
same one as as Doctor Who
yeah I think no
now I'm getting them all I'm getting
confused because we watched Tom Baker
was in one and he plays the sultan
that's what I'm saying no he was in the
one before that okay I think called this
the golden Voyager the seven Voyages of
Sinbad one of one of the two
yeah we watched like a bunch of them and
like in quick succession so it's like
the details of them kind of like yeah
and the very first one I think was from
another era I don't think it looked it
was still Ray harryhausen yeah I think
did the stop motion and in both in in
all of them
but uh there was something about the
first one that I think was kind of
different than the other ones I it's
been a long since I've seen them I
actually want to get them all on Blu-ray
they'd be good to have
they're very watchable yeah they're very
they're super fun they were like
as big as Star Wars was for me it was
before Star Wars came out and when Star
Wars came out it blue the other the the
Sinbad movies out of the water but this
is in terms of fantasy inside and and
special effects
Sinbad Sinbad movies are real good
um now Star Wars came out and that was a
British movie too A lot of people
thought it was American but that was
made in England most of it well yeah
they shot it they shot it in England
yeah and all most of the crew was
British as well yeah
and everybody in the Empire and
everything and flicking you know Boba
Fett and all that that all came later
but you know it was all British because
the British could deliver
you know real good at making handcrafted
stuff and professional unions and making
sets and uh you know they were they were
real good a lot better than the kind of
the half-assed [ __ ]
Hollywood would try to do in terms of
special effects best thing I ever saw
come out of Hollywood from that era
would have been like Logan's Run or
maybe like Silent Running remember with
Bruce Dern I felt Silent Running Oh no I
guess not I was thinking yeah that was
pretty good uh for the time but Star
Wars blew all that [ __ ] out of the water
yeah that's true yeah I was gonna think
too since we're talking about special
effects Dracula 80 1972 not a lot of
blood in it no not really no
um other than I mean there's that
there's that one scene where you know
Caroline Monroe is like on the altar or
whatever and there's like you know they
dump blood all over her boobies yeah but
you don't really see they were there
though people yeah
but there's I mean the the one scene too
that kind of made me laugh at it at its
um you know just it's blatantness yeah
was uh where you know toward the end
where uh Stephanie beacham's character
you know the the granddaughter
where she gets taken by Dracula and
she's like under Dracula sway or
whatever and she's laying there on the
thing and then Peter Cushing comes in
like he's gonna save her and whatnot but
she's like under her spell and there's
like a really funny shot where Peter
Cushing is just like kind of behind her
like talking it's like I gotta go kill
Dracula or whatever and then her boobs
are just like very prominent like in
front of his face yeah and it's just
like made me laugh yeah like with little
nip sticking up and everything and I'm
just like yep boobalicious yeah
I think there were even some um there
were some uh publicity Stills that came
out that had Stephanie Beacham and Peter
Cushing and I think there was some of
her with Christopher Lee too where she
was just like very obviously like down
like that and the dress was like just
barely like kind of like the top of the
areolas it's like it was super sure what
you demonstrate yet
well I don't have I don't have his low
credit card it's not yeah I mean hers
was just like it was really missing all
those clicks we had to get you back in
those little cut tops like in the
beginning of the show people it's like
it's gorgeous
porn star level stuff man
all right so uh do we do we have
anything else we need to say about
Dracula 80 1972 uh yeah don't discount
it if you haven't seen it don't avoid it
yeah you can see it yeah I know it kind
of gets derided but it is still like
pretty watchable it's watchable there's
other stuff there's stuff that I wish
they would have done with it and there's
like but it's it's pretty entertaining
so let's see some of the other ones
first but you know because if you
haven't seen any of them then I'd start
I mean the earlier ones are better like
yeah if you're gonna watch the whole
series like start with Dracula from 1958
yeah
um and then kind of see the boot but I
think this is probably one of the worst
ones but they're all pretty good they're
all still worth watching and like I said
it's got Christopher Lee and Peter
Cushing in it and that's always a good
time like I don't even care what's going
on in the rest of the movie as long as
those two guys are in it then I'll watch
it so uh yeah so that'll do it so for
this movie retrospective we'll see you
guys again on the next one bye